[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
nous allons essayer d'expliquer de
décrypter l'actualité avec des des
sujets brûlants parlera notamment des
des réunions non mixtes de de l'unef on
parlera des 50 ans de la pale des de ce
que l'on appelait des 343 c'est
de dire la pub pour la légalisation de
l'avortement on va parler aussi de ces
polémiques avec un certain nombre de
maire écologiste de l'euthanasie aussi
des kits débattu qui va être débattu à
l'assemblée nationale et pour parler de
sousse et suzanne perdriau bonjour
bonjour vous êtes conseiller régional de
l'ile-de-france
bonjour sandrine grandes banques bonjour
vous êtes la première à tous noirs de la
mairie de trappes est aussi est
également conseiller régional
ile-de-france toujours des mouvements
génération 1 florence père cadets choqué
bonjour vous êtes avocate au barreau de
versailles
stéphane manceau est toujours professeur
à l'université de versailles saint
quentin et doyen honoraire de cette
diversité et vincent couronne est aussi
enseignant à duvet ce q vous êtes
journaliste vous est aussi le fondateur
du mouvement des surligneurs qui traque
les fake news notamment dans le domaine
politique
et puis jean charles grey jouannic est
avec moi en plateau merci d'être venus
bonjour éditeurs et on retient tout de
suite montré deux dernières apparitions
de vos éditions du joug tumeurs de
yannick provost en plus c'est un fait le
local de l'étape puisqu'il habite au
chesnay
l'auteur va venir ici alors et c'est sur
un jeu vidéo fin c'est assez autour du
jeu vidéo transport entre la la
virtualité la réalité c'est assez
astucieux et est très très prenant et un
roman de frédéric bertin denis qui
s'appelle matador qui sera sad en
espagne évidemment en espagne et c'est
sur la corrida et alors ça devrait
déchaîner les passions parce que c'est
une enquête menée par deux policiers
espagnols y en a qui a foncé vraiment à
l'aficion à dos un aficionado pardon et
l'autre qui est absolument anti cauri
voilà oui il ya des vins très très fort
allié le niveau 1 un tueur en série qui
est très très bien campés alors avant
d'aborder des sujets dont j'ai un peu
parlé tout à l'heure
est-ce qu'il y en a un dont vous a
participé à des dîners cours destin
récemment n'ont peut-être pas à les
voilà partis dont on s'est dit nerveux
non ce qui est intéressant et je disais
ça c'est au fond ça a déclenché cette
petite polémique dont on ne sait pas si
elle est vraiment fondées ou pas l'ère
du soupçon et il ya un certain nombre de
ministres puisqu'on dit que des
ministres auraient participé à ces
dîners qui dont on parle leur lassitude
au fond il disait finalement c'est un
métier de chien et on est attaqué tout
le temps c'est vrai que cette ère du
soupçon et je parle de demander à un
père brio et sandrine gang qui veut sont
deux élus cette ère du soupçon pour jeu
contre des élus comptent
qu'est ce que vous en pensez alors mais
moi je trouve c'est évidemment un
contre-exemple de si c'est vrai parce
que c'est toujours je regarde vincent
magie c'est assez terrible oui si c'est
vrai c'est vraiment le contraire de
l'exemplarité donc c'est vrai qu'un élu
de la république
c'est l'article 1 c'est l'exemplarité
donc
ça de ce point de vue là c'est tout à
fait condamnable après c'est vrai que on
a toujours tendance à partir d'un
événement éminemment marginal quand même
à jeter une espèce d'eau propre contre
toute la classe politique
et ça c'est triste ça je trouve que
c'est pas parce qu'il ya il ya comme
dans tous les
comme dans tous les groupes d'individus
il ya toujours des des petits dés infime
minorité en fait qu'ils peuvent
effectivement se conduire de façon par
exemplaire et ça devient la généralité
c'est à dire qu'elle à partir d'un
exemple où il y aurait quelques élus
impliqués
ça devient tous les élus sont voilà ne
sont pas des gens et c'est alors que
williams mais c'est toujours ce thème
voilà c'est obscène grands groupes
justement sur ce soupçon qui peut peser
alors à tord ou à raison mais qui pèse
souvent sur les sur les élus sur la
classe politique peut-être moins
d'ailleurs dans les mairies 1 mais je
pense que ça concerne assez peu les élus
locaux pour le coup j'aimerais bien
prendre quand on parle exemplarité bien
sûr et si on trouve que c'est trop dur
d'être élu qu'on peut aller faire autre
chose et je pense que par cette ère du
soupçon je suis d'accord il faudrait
aussi le généraliser quand on parle de
ces jeunes qui sont irresponsables parce
qu'ils auraient été sans mal qu'on ait
le même regard sur ses pas une légende
c'est quelques jeunes c'est des moments
de carnaval à marseille c'est pareil
c'est pas tous des marseillais ces
quelques personnes qui ont sont mal
comportés
donc on est la même forme de tolérance
tout de même type de discours
quel que soit le public dont on parle
jean charles lajoie ni moi moi c'est
vrai que ce soit vrai et je je je
comprends très bien je dis
tout le monde est en train de devenir
fou et je veux dire qu'est ce que ça
peut faire je veux dire c'est ça n'a
aucune importance un dîner clandestins
que ce qu'est ce que ça veut dire quand
tout ça et est grotesque voici des élus
ou des ministres y participent c'est
vrai que ça donne quoi un birkin à bâle
qui n'a pas envie d'aller dîner dans un
restaurant et qui n'a pas envie de le
faire et c'est assez
c'est tout à fait humain je veux dire
peu importe et ce qui est déprimant dans
cette histoire c'est que sar déclenché
le côté le moins le moins beau de l'a22
de l'être humain c'est à dire tout de
suite le soupçon la délation la
recherche comme le disait madame on a on
a que ce tous les jeunes qui ont le
malheur de vouloir s'amuser de de vous
leur contaminer la france entière on va
aller les dénoncer on voit des gens dans
les rues qui sont là en train de pointer
un tel cas pas le masque pas sur le bout
du nez etc mais qu'on foute la paix aux
gens et qu'on arrête un petit peu c'est
tout cela que c'est vrai que la période
de la dénonciation est un peu reparti et
ceci nous rappelle quand wade désert peu
sombres de notre histoire sur ce sujet
vous voulez quelqu'un voulait intervenir
alors à puce ont dit qu'en fait ça ne
concerne qu'un seul oui ces faits qui
doit être exemplaire qu'on est tous les
deux restaurants je crois il ay leur
désir est tranquillement faire va faire
un dîner avec d'autres personnes enfin
oui moi ça me choque
oui non il n'y aurait qu'un seul mint la
seule restée comme on dit c'est c'est
beaucoup c'est peut-être et je pense que
si elle si le nom de ce ministre est
révélé je pense qu'il n'aura pas d'autre
choix que la démission dont on pourrait
balancer le nom et on ne savions pas
qu'ils sont ministres donc des risques
rien alors on va poser aux premiers
sujets l'assemblée nationale va discuter
cette semaine deux propositions de loi
autorisant l'euthanasie c'est le premier
thème de cette émission
[Musique]
voilà c'est une proposition de loi pour
légaliser le suicide assisté comme on le
dit qu'ils savent être débattue à
l'assemblée nationale
au fond peut-être stéphane leman sont
peut-être vous pouvez nous éclairer c
est un vieux serpent de mer quand même
la légalisation ou non de l'euthanasie
oui oui c'est un vieux serpent de mer
mais qui enfin la question c'est pas
tant celle de l'euthanasie que là la
question au sens large et je reprends
cette expression parce que je la trouve
tout à fait tout à fait fondé du droit à
mourir dans la dignité
c'est une question qui a qui a progressé
1 on n'est pas dans une situation de sur
place ni même de recul
la loi claisse leonetti dernier texte en
date permet avec la sédation profonde
l'arrêt des soins alors kiné qui n'est
pas peut pas appeler ça l'euthanasie
réellement mai mais qui au regard de la
volonté si tant est qu'elle soit qu'elle
soit identifiable de la volonté de
matignon ou bien telle qu'elle peut
texte être exprimée par par ses proches
je vous renvoie à 7 à cette triste
affaire vincent lambert par exemple on
peut maintenant avec toute une série de
précautions procédurales juridiques
éthiques mettre fin au traitement pour
ne pas verser dans un traitement une
obstination dans ce que le la loi
appelle l'obstination déraisonnable
donc il ya un pas supplémentaire à
franchir et qui alors mettez en cause au
delà de principe politique on le voit
avec la proposition de députés
falorni kiki qui met en cause des
convictions morales éthiques
philosophiques religieuses qui vont bien
au delà des clivages politiques
ce qu'on peut voilà la question mûri si
vous voulez elle mûrit d'autant que
d'autant plus que dans des systèmes
juridiques proches
je vous cite toujours la suisse ou
encore la belgique
coût désormais l'espagne et bien
d'autres on peut aller on peut aller au
delà on peut aller plus loin et c'est
cette je passe supplémentaire que la
proposition de loi propose avec moult
précautions d'ailleurs de franchir mais
bon pas qui ne sera manifestement pas
franchi jeudi dans la niche
parlementaire dont dispose le cette
proposition regarde l'obstruction qui
elle fait essentiellement de deux
députés
les républiques oui encore que vous avez
raison de rappeler que ce n'était pas un
clivage politique puisque leonetti est
je crois un membre du parti républicain
derrière et kehl qui est l'auteur de
cette loi qui a fait une avancée
considérable
sandrine grand-combe sur ce sujet si
vous étiez députés vous seriez favorable
à ouvrir la voie suicide assisté
je reprendrai exactement la position
évoqué ses fans dans son c c'est le
choix de mourir dans la dignité et qu'on
sorte enfin d'un système hypocrite où on
a fait un pas mais on n'a pas osé aller
jusqu'au bout et je crois qu'il est
temps plus de temps pour toi la
souffrance de certaines familles encore
aujourd'hui d'être cohérent dans ce que
l'on veut et je voterai mais des
demandes
alors une fois qu'ils ont goûté une peur
brio alors moi je serais lancé c'est un
sujet évidemment donc personnellement
une et une immense humilité évidemment
un ca tous alors alain team vraiment et
je pense que avant
je ne suis pas sûr de vouloir
institutionnalisée l'euthanasie mais
parce que quand on entend beaucoup de
témoignages
en fait c'est d'abord un échec
thérapeutique et je pense que il faut
d'abord plutôt chercher tous les chemins
vers une fin de vie apaisante et où nos
quinquas écouter des témoignages ou des
gens partent dans les pays où c'est
autorisé parce que il ya eu un échec
thérapeutique et qu'il n'a pas été
accompagnée en fait beaucoup de gens se
disent abandonnés abandonné et donc et
partent donc parce que ils ont été
abandonnées s'il avait été accompagnée
peut-être ne sera-t-il pas partie est ce
que je voulais dire également c'est que
je pense que c'est aussi une un esprit
de société c'est à dire que il faut
vraiment que la société fasse un effort
pour ne pas laisser les personnes âgées
sur le bas côté c'est à dire qu'on a
l'impression dans notre société que
passer 80 ans
on est globalement bon à mettre un peu
de côté il ya la fracture numérique les
gens ont disent ils n'ont pas accès mais
on s'en fiche quelque part dans les
magazines de mode de société quand est
ce qu'on parle des gens plus de 80 ans
c'est comme s'ils n'existaient pas et
donc je pense que c'est ça va au delà et
qu' il ya vraiment un effort d'inclusion
et s'il ya des personnes âgées qui sont
dans les sociétés africaines par exemple
d une génération éminemment protéger et
valoriser nous dévalorise cette voie là
ce sont des gens on sera tous on aura
tous 80 ans devra tous 80 peut-être 10 a
tous voila et je pense que si un sujet à
mettre fin à la consultation citoyenne
c'est bien celui là
moi je verrais bien une consultation
citoyenne et vous avez raison de dire de
parler de ces personnes âgées
ce qui est d'autant plus étonnant que
que on va avoir en ne serait-ce qu'en
france une majorité de la plus grande
proportion de la population c'est des
plus de 65 ans dont c'était très tôt
donc à la fois au sein de la majorité et
qu'on oublie un peu france mercredi
choqué sur ce sujet fait d'accord avec
un père de vidéo mais lorsque surtout
céder les centres de soins palliatifs
il y en a assez donc ça c'est au delà de
la problématique des personnes âgées
si je n'y suis pas il n'y a pas assez de
son arrivée à développer beaucoup plus
c'est sans que ce soit palliatifs pour
accompagner dans les meilleures
conditions possibles les personnes qui
veulent mourir dans la dignité
effectivement on n'aurait pas aller
aussi loin sur la problématique que
l'euthanasie alors ce que je regrette
beaucoup ce qui est de l'équipement
cette loi ce projet de loi
de toute façon doit être présenté fait
mention de peut être débattu pendant 24
heures ce qui paraît jeudi qui périt
tout 24 heures est effectivement de
toute façon ce sera parce qu'ils sont en
cause et donc rien se passer je vis et
c'est bien ce qui est dommage aussi sur
ce projet de loi c'est qu'en belgique on
prend le temps de d'annoncer dans cette
dans ce chemin vers la porte puisque la
personne a un mois pour réfléchir et la
peau les doigts la personne à 24 heures
se rétracter en plus mais ce qui me
paraît vraiment hyper court donc pas ya
certains points qui sont qui sont un peu
contestable même si effectivement il
faut avancer sur ce droit à la dignité
pas sur le droit à mourir parce que là
ça pose question philosophique
religieuse sur la dignité à de
l'accompagnement je pense
qu'effectivement si on développe c'est
soit ces centres de soins palliatifs on
ira aussi un peu dense est bon pour être
très précis parler de projet c'est une
proposition de loi et c'est ce qui
explique aussi puisque c'est quand même
le gouvernant qui est m
les travaux du parlement qu'on en
discute très peu parce que yao fu ilias
approuvé cette proposition n'a pas le
soutien du gouvernement
georges haldas mais il ya un télescopage
curieux ça fait un an que ont confiné
qu'on condamne quasiment à mort les
vieux dans les ehpad et là maintenant à
l'assemblée et au sénat on voudrait nous
faire croire qu'on va essayer de les
faire mourir dans la dignité mais déjà
qu'on les fasse vivre dans la dignité
je veux dire on a confiné et on continue
à confiner les gens de façon scandaleuse
et tout le monde s'en fout et voilà donc
alors bien évidemment je reprends le
terme de stéphane sait très bien qu'ils
qui oserait dire qu'on n'est pas pour le
droit de mourir dans la dignité
juste un papier de michel houellebecq
dans le figaro une civilisation qui
légalise l'euthanasie perd tout droit au
respect et à un moment il parle de la
dignité dit mais moi je vais perdre mes
cheveux mes poumons vont y passer je
vais sans doute devenir aveugle
impuissant je vais je vais voilà faire
mes besoins sur moi etc mais disent
assez de cette vieillissement c'est vrai
la dignité voilà si c'est ça la dignité
bon port et alors il n
il a une réflexion qui moi me paraît
assez intéressante c'est de dire il dit
voilà si je disais un jour je veux
mourir
j'aimerais que des proches me disent ben
reste un peu avec nous et au fond
vincent collet c'est intéressant
est ce que finalement le le l'ouverture
à l'euthanasie c'est pas une faso pour
les vivantes se débarrasser un peu des
personnes qui sont en effet importantes
qui sont en effet souffrante qui sauvent
gatin tu parles par là j'ai pas le
vieillissement
c'est au fond c'est ce qu'il dit ou el
bec j'avoue pâte risque sur cette
question j'ai comment dire à dire j'ai
pas beaucoup d'avis et je suis un peu
frustré effectivement mais c'est pour
des questions effectivement de droit
parlementaire qu'on a qu'un seul jour de
débat à l'assemblée nationale sur ce
sujet la loi plesk leonetti c'était deux
jours a noté par l'assemblée
tout c'est trop peu pour un sujet comme
celui là je ne suis pas certain en fait
ça soit l'orientation la direction que
vient d'en parler michel houellebecq la
crise sanitaire a bien montré que au
contraire vous faites on prenait soin
quand même dans une large mesure des
personnes âgées notamment et qu'on
refusait de les laisser tomber
en réalité qu'est ce que c'est le
passage entre la loi plaisent leonetti
et cette proposition de loi sur
l'euthanasie c'est simplement un
élargissement des possibilités en fait
de pouvoir mettre fin aux jours d'une
personne qui est malade dans une
situation irréversible
on dit bien que c'est dans des cas
graves et incurables qui inflige des
souffrances irréversible
voilà c'est la loi de lèse leonetti
aujourd'hui c'est dans des cas plus
stricte où on est en phase terminale
voilà donc c'est pas c'est pas on n'est
pas en train de légaliser le suicide
assisté en énergie en fait le droit à
mourir dans la dignité à des situations
plus large que celle qu'on avait jusque
là il n'y a pas de changement de nature
en quelque sorte c'est simplement un
élargissement de la loi que les appétits
donc mais mais je suis d'accord sur le
fait que l'on avait avec avec florence
et avec vos pâtes risque on aurait pu
avoir un peu plus de débat sur le sujet
c'est sur cette phrase on a une grosse
gang par exemple cette phrase de
houellebecq une civilisation qui
légalise l'euthanasie perd tout droit au
respect je trouvais que c'est trop
polémique où on peut comprendre un peu
cette prise de position et du web est
qu'un donc on n'est pas on n'est pas
plus étonné quel que soit le sujet il ya
une forme de aussi volontaire de
provocation même s'ils croient qu'il a
ce qu'il dit mais moi j'aimerais bien
qu'on confonde pas la question du
vieillissement et de la dignité à mourir
vivre dans de bonnes conditions le plus
longtemps possible
et puis la question de qui est posée là
qui peut toucher demain n'importe quelle
personne qui suit un accident de voiture
suite à une maladie effectivement
incurable se retrouve confronté son
choix personnel de vivre ou de mourir et
ce quand houellebecq dit moi je
je vais aux dégradés physiquement à
terra et je peux pas forcément arrêté
pour autant c'est son choix dire la
question s'est posée la question c'est
d'avoir le libre choix et c'est pour ça
qu'à mon avis on quand vous regardez les
sondages d'opinion les français sont
très très largement favorable à ce qu'on
évolue sur cette question là c'est vrai
que ça pose une question presque
philosophique ses fans montceau c'est
l'ouverture du droit aux autres et ce
que dit très bien sans doute encore
bouffon c'est ouvrir les droits ce
qu'ils veulent et ce qu'ils ne veulent
pas sont pas du tout glisse denis passé
mais on avait vu ça pour le mariage pour
tous aussi sa chope des gens c'est à
dire que le mariage pour tous dans le vé
pa o o ce qu'ils veulent et se marier le
fait de pouvoir se marier mais il ne
tolérait pas qu'on ouvre à d'autres
personnes et là c'est un peu la même le
même raisonnement c'est assez
intéressant ça c'est aussi une question
de enfin je vais dire civilisation
d'histoire d'habitude de confort de
penser de mon point de vue tout ce qui
tout ce qui peut aller vers un surcroît
d'auto détermination individuelle sur
ces questions-là constitue un progrès le
mariage pour tous cet état c'était un
progrès qui était attendu cet
élargissement des possibilités de mourir
dans des situations bien particulières
qu'un sans couronne a eu raison de le
rappeler c'est aussi de mon point de vue
un progrès vers tout ce qui peut
contribuer à l'autodétermination c'est à
dire à la liberté à la liberté de chacun
et je pense que la nôtre notre
civilisation fait à chaque fois un un
pas vers le ver le ver le meilleur vers
le progrès lorsqu'elle permet
l'autodétermination en dépit de tout de
toutes les opinions qu'on peut dire noir
sur la question mais en effet il s'agit
pas de l'imposer il s'agit de le
permettre dans des situations
particulières
des personnes qui ardemment le
souhaitent et ça n'est pas aujourd'hui
ça n'est pas le cas au jour alors on va
passer au deuxième sujet c'est séné
d'une déclaration de la maire de
poitiers et qui s'appelle léonore
monconduit qui est qui et écologistes et
voilà qui dit au fond les enfants
devraient pas rêver à devenir des
pilotes monter dans des avions
c'est fini tout ça c'est un peu
polémique à la brouille est apte à venir
danser la jaunisse et même bien pire je
me permets de vous reprendre patrie ça
ne l'a pas dit ne devrait pas et ne
doivent plus il ne faut plus que les
enfants rêvent l'aviation et rêve de
voler alors que les planeurs parce que
les planeurs el bulli point oublié
d'être sans cesse et c'est juste un an
mais en tas de la bêtise enfin je veux
dire qu'est ce que c'est mais est ce que
on imagine si quelqu'un d'un autre parti
politique du rassemblement national de
n'importe quel parti avait osé dire de
quoi doivent être faits les rêves des
enfants
mais ce serait une révolution on aurait
le mrap on aurait tout le monde dans les
rues alors mais la déclaration était
condamnée aussi bien par marine le pen
que par jean luc mélenchon mais mais au
four alors au delà de ça après on peut
parler de maladresse peut-être etc
ça pose quand même un vrai problème c
est ce qu il faut pas quand même changer
un peu de logiciels on a en a quand même
des ddd des défis environnementaux alors
le défi c'est très important
est ce que le défi environnemental pour
madame monde conduit c'est d'arrêter les
pilotes de canadair var étaient des
pilotes d'hélicoptère qui donne du salut
d'arrêter de de stopper thomas pesquet
n'en sont donc dans son élan de stopper
les évacuations sanitaires des gens qui
sont baladés qui sont envoyées de d'un
hôpital à un autre là
en réanimation ils prennent l'avion est
ce que tout ça faut arrêter pour ces
essais calembredaines intellectuelle
mais non mais enfin quel sens et tous
les amis on les réduit les levées non il
faut arrêter de rêver à l'avion il faut
arrêter de rêver de voler il faut il
faut rééduquer nos enfants jeudi on est
on est dans le lait supprimer les
subventions des aéro club on sait
d'ailleurs très peu avec elle qu'elle
supprime ce qu'elle veut mais ces sept
paroles horribles qui est de dire il
faut que les enfants rêvent d'autre
chose il faut interdire aux enfants de
rêver ça je vais dire mais qu'elle fasse
chier c'est le clfc le fascisme un
visage vert enfin c'est cela c'est
peut-être ça peut être cette explication
ça peut être aussi bas il faut peut-être
prendre conscience des dangers qui do
qui nous menacent sandrine grand groupe
vous êtes génération mais vous êtes vous
avez une conception très très forte de
l'environnement de l'écologie qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
repro micro logic coin de gauche c'est
alors je leur dis qu'on peut en dire que
cette conscience forte par rapport à
prémat qui convergent pas que j'espère
qu'aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qu'on
partage touche en fait même sur ce
plateau d'un petit premiers intervenants
redoutent un peu plus moi je peux
comprendre que le propos aient choqué
parce qu'il ya une représentation aussi
depuis toujours de ce qu'est le fait de
voler là on a on a monté manic là qui
est symboliquement très forte en dans ce
qu'elle a dit c'est que elle même quand
elle était en france répartis de céret
et ce qu'elle a voulu dire à mon avis
c'est que on était dans un moment il
fallait changer de modèles récents sont
proposés
qui peut douter aujourd'hui quand on
voit que ce matin encore on s'est levés
alors que i les 30° semaine dernière et
qu'aujourd'hui il y avait de la neige et
que tout âge les qui peut tout de suite
aujourd'hui on a une vraie des réponses
à apporter aux problématiques que l'on
vit aujourd'hui qui sont des
problématiques climatiques lourdes brio
alors sur cette intervention alors sur
le fond c'est vrai que c'est
insupportable
la façon dont ça a été dit c'est
absolument insupportable
on est dans le dogmatisme à son plus
haut degré et c'est pas comme ça qu'on
va sensibiliser la population a
effectivement là où tout le monde est
d'accord faire des efforts sur sur
l'écologie et le respect de
l'environnement moi je vois là mais je
pense que c'est un sujet évidemment que
nous partageons tous
mais c'est eux par justement en
affrontant le problème en face et en en
allant vers la recherche ce qui est
actuellement en cours pour
l'aéronautique d'ailleurs inverse du
moins du moins polluants et par des
actions au contraire extrêmement
concrètes et du quotidien des gens qu'on
arrivera à avancer c'est vrai que je
vois par exemple à la région il ya eu la
coop régional qui a permis de formaliser
une consultation avec près de 200
propositions extrêmement concrètes
il ya dans le 4 milliards celle
consacrée à l'écologie sur cette année
passée 2020 et sept années à venir avec
de multiples actions du quotidien et et
de la recherche donc je pense que c'est
plus en faisant qu'en dix ans et en
connaissant pas réellement son sujet je
crois que beaucoup de gens parlent en
plus sans connaître réellement tout le
monde y un peu n'importe quoi et de
temps en temps c'est vrai qu'on a envie
d'entendre les paroles d'expert surtout
sur ce sujet voilà c'est vrai que cette
déclaration vient après d'autres
déclarations de mr écologistes sur les
sapins de noël sur le tour de france etc
c'était pas de montceau c'est vrai que
au fond est ce que il met il faut des
gaffes où il met le doigt sur des
problèmes peu qui fâchent
non mais mettre le doigt sur des
questions qui fâchent c'est bien c'est
aussi le rôle des élus y compris des
élus locaux expliqué comment dirais-je
mettre l'accent sur des problématiques
en proposant des solutions qui ne vont
pas nécessairement dans le sens du vent
c'est aussi le rôle
des élus sauf que moi en effet je suis
exactement ce que ce que ce que disait
sandrine grand gant bm perdriau à
l'instance à dire qu on est tous
conscients des impératifs et en
attendant certains agissent mais mais
d'autres parlent et parlent un peu dans
le vide
c'est ces grands élus c'est ces mères
écologistes militent de mon point de vue
contre leur propre cause en caricaturant
et c'est vrai je suis d'accord on sent
derrière un un dogmatisme qui est qui et
de mauvais aloi enfin qui est qui et qui
est totalement inefficace sur le sur le
sur le plan politique enfin de mon point
de vue est engagée pas si si les
électeurs c'est parce que j'y retrouve
mais enfin moi de toute façon je ce type
de discours dogmatique et pour moi
totalement inaudible s'entraîne grand
gang justement sur ce plan politique on
voit bien que la gauche l'écologie vous
et génération fait partie de cette
mouvance la essaye de 2,2 de se
regrouper peut-être pour l'épauler en
vue des élections présidentielles
notamment
est ce que ce genre de déclarations ça
rend pas les choses plus difficiles
finalement ce matin il faut aussi
relativiser
moi je pense qu'il ya aussi un
emballement médiatique là où il ya une
concomitance des surréactions par
rapport à des propos qui peuvent choquer
chantant kinois m'interroge beaucoup
quand même
j'ai pas entendu autant de réactions
quand
je suis vos qui avait par exemple
supprimés l'un de subventions à des
associations humanitaires ou l'art
peut-être le rêve des enfants aussi du
molière vous pouvez être impactés là
bizarrement il n'y avait pas de réaction
importante de la classe médiatique et je
pensais aussi derrière dans une période
où on est juste avant les cantonales et
régionales et les présidentielles
évidemment une instrumentalisation
politique de tout ça laissons à leur
égard si des propos peuvent paraître
maladroit
est ce que il ya besoin de mettre à ce
point les la lumière sur ces promos là
ce qu'il faut juger c'est les politiques
et il faut croire qu'on est aussi dans
une instrumentalisation politique des
paroles relativisé henri jean charles
lajoie deeply français merkel et comme
vous le titrez les instants les sapins à
noël patrouille de france le tour de
france maintenant les rêves des enfants
ce que je vais paraphraser la mosquée de
strasbourg a parlé je crois que les
maires écologistes les maires
écologistes south toucher à ça qu'on les
reconnaît donc ça c'est une une
référence à jacques audiard michel
michel audiard voilà vraiment super
cadeau qu'est va sans couronne sur ce
sujet rapidement parce que où il
faudrait compris brio je suis choqué dit
en accord avec ce qui a été dit sur le
fond il ya un problème déontologique il
faut pas se cacher c'est vrai que
chauffant la façon d'interdire le rêve
de toujours un peu être coté
totalitariste qui peut choquer va se
faire oui pardon je vais faire un
commentaire politique qui sort de mon
domaine du droit mais je pense en fait
que c'est vraiment une opinion
personnelle que les verts en fait
il était sorti vainqueur sinon
électoralement mais du moins
médiatiquement des élections municipales
qu'on se rapproche de la présidentielle
et qu'en réalité les opposants en fait
font feu de tout bois pour pour essayer
de ridiculiser le moindre propos qu'ils
peuvent qu'ils peuvent tenir
je trouve ça assez dommage je sais pas
si je pense pas que le gouvernement
lorsqu'il a proposé d'interdire les
pailles en plastique
il a été ridiculisé parce qu'on allait
ruiner les anniversaires des petits
enfants qu'ils ne pourraient pas à
prendre à bail en plastique voilà je
trouve que c'est tout ça est un petit
peu grossier et c'est dommage mais c'est
vrai que les couverts en bois c'est pas
très agréable je trouve enfin bon on va
passer au sujet suivant cette polémique
qu'il ya eu lieu après la décision de
l'unef de faire des réunions qui ne soit
pas ouverte à tous ce qu'on appelle des
rayons non mixtes consacrée notamment
aux discrimination raciale alors et
voilà le hénaff a dit c'est bayrou pas
de raison que des blancs participe à des
réunions de ce genre puisque par nature
ne sont pas victimes de discriminations
raciales évidemment levée de boucliers
au gouvernement jean michel blanquer
reparle de nature fasciste
bruno retailleau eric ciotti veulent
poursuivre le syndicat à gauche il ya
ceux qui comprennent le neuf
ils soutiennent comme jean luc mélenchon
et audrey pulvar et puis il ya des gens
comme anne hidalgo comme manuel valls
qui ont des positions beaucoup plus qui
condamne évidemment le syndicat sur ce
sur ce sujet alors est ce qu'on ne fait
pas moi c'est la question que je me pose
est ce qu'on n'en fait pas trop après
tout sont pas des réunions plénières du
syndicat sont des réunions sur des
sujets précis sur les discriminations
raciales
c'est vrai qu'on peut se demander est ce
que est ce que des blancs de kroll grand
chose à dire sur ce sujet l'agent sam
davies
je crois que là on touche le fond c'est
à dire que si on considère que parce
qu'on est pas noir on ne peut pas
s'intéresser à ce qui touche à la
population noire
c'est ça me paraît totalement aberrant
ça c'est la première chose deuxièmement
est ce qu'on imagine la tollé et qui
serait le tollé qui serait totalement
justifiée si on faisait une
manifestation pour s'intéresser aux
problèmes de la population blanche
interdite aux noirs et aux jaunes est ce
qu est ce qu on imagine juste ça sur un
panneau avec interdit aux noirs mais on
serait revenue ou où on serait ton est
ce qu'on aurait wallemme pulvar madame
hidalgo qui aura vu c'est une bonne idée
mais les noirs n'ont rien à faire dans
cette
mais on est chez les fous
enfin je veux dire c'est juste adhérents
le simple fait qu'on en débatte et me
paraît une folie totale je dire il ya
des choses qu'il faut condamner mais b
mais bientôt on va en arriver à discuter
peut-être du nazisme on dire bah oui
mais peut-être y a plus de limite à ce
débat il n'y a pas de débat on ne fait
pas de choses en france interdite aux
blancs et puis c'est tout on fait pas de
trucs interdits ou noir c'est patrick
interdit aux arabes
c'est la fin de la république c'est la
fin de tout perdre rio et j'ai justement
audrey pulvar on en parle et veut être
candidate de la gauche aux régionales
à votre avis c'est une gaffe qu'elle
fait ou 7 une tête chercheuse d'un
nouvel électorat
c'est très triste
c'est très triste alors que tout le
monde n'a de cesse que de vouloir faire
société
quand on est une reine fait société avec
chacun comme il est et c'est on ne cesse
de diviser divisé divisé ça devient
vraiment je trouve indécent et j'ai été
très séduite par l'interview de cette
violoniste international jambes jungle
qui a été interviewé par sonia mabrouk
il ya quelques jours et qui disait il
n'ya pas non plus plus bel accueil que
la france la france m'a accueilli et
c'est comme si on disait par exemple la
france est raciste parce qu'il n'ya pas
de chinois dans l'équipe de foot du psg
par exemple vous voyez c'est un peu ça
c'est la france est raciste au chinois
parce qu'il n'ya pas de chinois dans
l'équipe de france du psg ou une autre
équipe et je trouve que c'est ça devient
ça devient par des en fait ce sont des
déclarations qui sont indignes d'intérêt
qui à la fois évidemment sont dignes
d'intérêt tellement elles sont
choquantes
on n'arrive pas à ne pas résister on
n'arrive pas à résister à ce genre de
provocation alors qu'il faudrait il
faudrait pouvoir résister à ce genre de
provocations parce que c'est c'est
tellement c'est tellement anti anti
société et en ti voilà cette espèce
d'objectifs qu'on a tous de faire
société
et ces gens là c'est grave voilà ces
gens là ne sont pas responsables sans
couronne vous comprenez l'attitude de
l'unef
je trouve que les l'unef va probablement
un peu loin dans ses dents c'est dans
ces combats
mais je voudrais quand même un petit peu
relativiser parce que il repart les cinq
écuries les toits que deux groupes de
parole ce sont des groupes de discussion
et on n'est pas du tout dans l'idée de
dire on va commencer à faire des
manifestations de blanc des
manifestation de noirs des restaurants
pour les noirs étaient alors là ce sont
que des réunions des groupes de parole
comme on fait par une réunion pour les
alcooliques anonymes où on n'accepte pas
que des non alcoolique assiste
maintenant il ya quand même un gc
effectivement l'imprégnation de tout un
tas de deux bien deux courants de pensée
qui vous viennent essentiellement
d'amérique du nord et qui en france de
ces roses un peu sur effectivement une
sorte de racialisation du débat
politique et du débat public et ça il
faudrait éviter vraiment que ça oui
sandrine grands groupes c'est vrai que
yahia 7,7
cette influence nord-américaine du
traitement par parlera ci pourtant
propos pour peu qu'elles existent ce qui
fait ce qui est quand même là ne pas pas
sûr du tout ça nous vient vraiment des
états unis à cette position de
victimisation
comment vous analyser ça moi je voulais
répondre à la question vous avez causés
au départ est ce qu'on en fait trop
oui je pense qu'on en fait trop ce que
disait as encore une veste avant on
parle de coûts qui se disent extrêmement
deux fois dans l'année je crois qu'ils
sont des coûts de parole et on en fait
un sujet politique majeur alors que le
vrai sujet de faire le cas on devrait
aujourd'hui échanger c'est la question
la carte étudiante la question des
conditions d'enseignement des conditions
d'études des étudiants ça c'est le vrai
sujet aujourd'hui c'est les files
d'attentes pour les restos du coeur des
étudiants ça c'est le sujet majeur
au lieu de ça on instrumentalise un
sujet qui peut interroger et je
l'entends et qui n'est pas aujourd'hui
le sujet majeur que l'on devrait que
l'on devrait être prêté et on arrive
un jeu absolument délirant à ce que ce
soit justement le procès des victimes
aujourd'hui qui est français et alors
dans le vocabulaire là on est dans le
grand n'importe quoi
et moi je suis une formation je suis
historienne de formation mais je pense
que pour les collectes de droit on
serait dans la même logique et les
mouvements à sens pas en arriver à ce
que a aujourd'hui on parle de
totalitarisme on parle fascisme à tout
bout de champ quel que soit maintenant
l'europe on a affaire à quelqu'un il est
fasciste
ça devient n'importe quoi les mots ont
un sens et que ce soit le ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui commettent lui
même ce genre de propos je trouve ça
très inquiétant sur le niveau de départ
et niveau intellectuel en fait de ce
pays aujourd'hui stéphane manceau est
est ce que justement par de petites
choses qui sont des réunions
rires il ya je reprends ce que disaient
certaines robes ou faux le problème de
la discrimination on l'a traité
peut-être de manière républicaine avec
tout le monde mais enfin il existe
toujours il est peut-être peut-être
aussi c'est un moyen différent de
traiter cette question
après tout on pourrait se poser le
problème mais c'est vrai que derrière
tout ça il ya peut-être toute cette
question d'assignation à l'origine qui
est pas très compatible en effet avec ce
que sont l'histoire et les valeurs de la
république
vous avez raison je souscris est ce que
vous dites mais jacquet lequel quelques
observations sur 7 sur cette question la
première c'est que cette ce concept de
race il est il est infondée on le sait
on le sait scientifiquement il a écrit
sandrine grand angle c'est le ciem
humains et historienne récupérer pendant
des décennies par par l'extrême droite
gobineau maurras camus et s'est donc
c'est un concept qui est on le sait
totalement arbitraire qu'est ce que
c'est que qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
blanc moi je ne sais pas si je suis
blanc qu'est ce que c'est qu'un racisées
puisque c'est le terme le qu'il convient
d'utiliser qui vient vue
du système étasunien moi je sais pas la
présidente de l'unef se présente comme
la première présentera six loges de ce
syndicat qu'est ce que ça va mais le
nydus
à partir de quel degré sur le lui ans y
est on est on est racisées ce critère de
la race il est insupportable parce qu'il
est totalement arbitraire
le critère sexuelle en revanche lui il
est beaucoup plus objectif quand on
pense que le groupe de parole deux
groupes de paroles de femmes qui ont
subi des des agressions des violences
etc
là je comprend à peu près parce que je
sais à peu près distinguer ce qui est un
homme et une femme
je ne sais pas en revanche distingué le
blanc du nom blanc je ne peux pas le
faire donc c'est accepter que cette
exclusion et s'est par ailleurs cette
construction d'homogénéité
elle est totalement artificielle et puis
il ya une autre une autre observation
que qu'on peut faire c'est que
finalement se ramène on ramène des
concepts d'un système le système
étasunien qui a connu une histoire mais
complètement différente de la nôtre
aux antipodes n'oublions pas quand même
que dans les états du sud des états unis
le système ségrégationniste a perduré
jusqu'en 1964 jusqu'à ce que la cour
suprême y mette fin
alors on posait séparés mais égaux mais
on sait ce à quoi ça conduisait en
réalité à mettre justement à distinguer
les gens et à distinguer leurs droits en
réalité leur dignité en fonction de
critères totalement arbitraire là encore
de critères ségrégationniste et donc on
est de mon point de vue et ses essais
c'est plus que dommage c'est
insupportable aux antipodes du message
universaliste alors chez bien ça
fonctionne pas comme ça devrait
fonctionner ça fonctionne peut-être même
ou encore moins bien qu'avant mais est
ce que c'est une raison pour abandonner
et pour nous orienter vers un système
parce que c'est la question c'est parce
pas ce que fait l'unef lui n'est fait
de ce point de vue là comme sur d'autres
d'ailleurs dans une espèce de deux
naufrages enfin moi c'est pas c'est pas
l'unef ça fait vieux con je vous accorde
que j'ai connu quand j'étais étudiant ça
n'a absolument plus rien à voir
il est devenu très compliqué discuté
aujourd'hui avec une aile ce n'était pas
le cas il ya eu des des très belles
choses pour tout est fait par ce
problème parce par ce syndicat
mais qui tire on tire on partiront verte
une note dissemblances plutôt que de
s'assembler entre soi cet entre soi il
est insupportable et il n'est pas
seulement le fait de l'unef où il est
fait d'un discours qui aujourd'hui hélas
ce reste un discours extrêmement de mon
point de vue relativement confiné
relativement cantonné il faut pas
surinterpréter non plus mais c'est de
mon point de vue un discours qui est un
discours qui est inacceptable en ce
mercredi choqué je suis assez d'accord
sur le plan à universelle avec ce que
dit stéphane minson
et je pense qu'il faut revenir puisque
le sujet cette réunion qui est
exclusivement réservé des personnes
noires
on a vu des groupes de parole comme
disait stéphane avec des femmes et sujet
justement de violence et ses paroles il
ya peut-être encore sur les gays sur des
personnes qui ont été voilà des choses à
se dire mais entre elles
parce que peut-être que personne ne
pourrait ne pas comprendre et on peut
pas dénier le fait que des personnes qui
sont noirs subissent des discriminations
raciales de manière assez fréquentes et
qu'il ya un racisme france à l'encontre
à des personnes noires et qui est un
groupe de parole entre elles ou qu'elles
expriment ce qu'elles ressentent et
qu'elles échangent sur leurs souffrances
de discrimination raciale par l'a9 on a
fait un peu importe moi ça me choque pas
comme des femmes peuvent
aussi entre elles parler de choses dont
elle souffre donc je suis d'accord qu'il
faut faire société qu'on soit tous
ensemble
je pense qu'on monte en épingle c'est ce
groupe de parole et cette réunion alors
qu'il y en a plein d'autres qui ne
choque pas forcément disait sur les
années les alcooliques anonymes à ceux
qui peuvent pas ils sont pas tolérés
mais il ya des groupes de parole et je
moi je suis intéressé par ce parent
après derrière il faut que ça débouche
sur autour du groupe parlera puisse
mélanger et faire société est mélangée
avec avec avec d'autres personnes avec
des blancs avec un des jaunes d'avec ce
que vous voulez mais en l'état via une
question d'efficacité de la lutte contre
les discriminations qui est qui qui qui
pourraient se poser ça draine grand bain
un mot sur ce que disait stéphane
mention peut-être en tant qu'historienne
finalement c'est à dire ceux sur ce
renvoi à l'origine sur sept retours de
la race d'autres c'est christophe
scientifiquement elle n'existe pas non
mais c'est tout à fait d'accord avec
l'intervention précédente
je pense que abandonné il peut y avoir
les hésiter universaliste on partage
tous et puis il ya la réalité du terrain
il ya des gens qui de fait sont plus
discriminée que d'autres et que j'ai
besoin d'en parler ça me paraît légitime
et oui enfin vous regardez les
statistiques sur les les contrôles de
police va il ya un fait c'est un certain
nombre de policiers en france
eux font bien la différence entre un
blanc et un non blancs peut-être que
nous ne sait pas le faire mais où ils le
font que ce qu'on voit dans les
statistiques
les contrôles sont tout à fait
disproportionnée dans un sens et donc
voila c'était réalité donc qu'il ne nous
plaisent pas forcément qu'il faut bien
perdriau peut-être pour conclure nous en
sommes je me soigne et me suis un peu
étonné par le tonalité des propos de
beaucoup de
des gens autour de cette table enfants
autour de cet écran j'ai l'impression
que plus rien n'est grave à chaque fois
on y va aubin madame mauconduit et les
rêves d'enfants
c'est pas très grave des réunions
seulement pour les noirs c'est pas très
grave y'a plus rien de grave on accepte
tout à chaque fois on trouve au bas oui
mais au fond on peut donc on va dans le
mur et un klaxon
c'est juste dramatique qu'on considère
justement tout est grave se détendre un
peu notre mode et on débat de tous pour
dire que rien n'est grave qu'on peut
tout accepter aux beaufs double pas très
grave
on trouve toujours un petit billet pour
dire bah oui mais c'est pas grave là je
veux dire c'est des noirs entre bon ben
on va les laisser voilà cdh et écolo
sont révélateurs des points c'est
stéphane mention qu'il ya un discours
entre père et mère parce qu'on l'a
interrompu vokoun qui est grave
jean-charles c'est la discrimination
raciale oui bon bah quand même oui dont
mais c'est vrai que c'est oui c'est vrai
que jusqu'à présent dans un sens
seulement nommé jusqu'à présent le fait
d'avoir d'avoir des réunions où tout le
monde pouvait y aller n'a pas quand même
résolu cette question
donc on peut se dire peut-être qu'il
faut procéder autrement après savourer
ce que vous pensez que des réunions et
que des noirs je sais pas ce que je dis
que leurs cadets choqué disais c'est
vrai que ya des rayons de femmes sur les
violences faites aux femmes qui sauf
qu'ils sont réservés aux femmes et aux
l'on peut comprendre alors vous me direz
il ya 50% de femmes 50% donne
allez on va passer peut-être que ça sera
peut-être le dernier sujet
malheureusement de 2,7 de cette émission
parce qu'il nous reste plus que 6 me dit
c'est des 50 ans de la peine qu'on
appelait le label des 343 lebon
a été rajoutée ensuite des 343
qui disait je me suis fait avorter
[Musique]
c'est le 5 avril 1971 qui ait paru se
manifeste dans lequel 343 femmes donc
affirmer qu'elle s'était fait avorter
c'est vrai que l'interruption de
grossesse était interdite elle sera
votée en 1975 sous l'impulsion de valéry
giscard d'estaing et de simone veil -le
sandrine grands groupes c'est un acte
fondateur pour le pour les femmes et
pour le féminisme
oui de manière assez évidente je crois
que si on en parle aujourd'hui c'est
clairement parce que c'est un sujet qui
est rentré dans l'histoire avec les 50
ans de parler mais qui n'est pas une
histoire complètement fini puisqu'il ya
la question de l'augmentation de la
durée aujourd'hui qui est posée et je
pense qu'il faut aussi là qu'on aille
jusqu'au bout de la réflexion et que la
loi évolue pour permettre de passer deux
semaines à 14 semaines cède les enfants
qui est posée au moment de
l'anniversaire de cette fois il ya une
proposition de loi qui était danseuse
qui était rejetée à une peur briola
aussi sur le c'est intéressant quand
même des femmes qui se rebellent contre
l'ordre établi contre la loi alors moi
je suis évidemment c'est un acte
fondateur vient évidemment et je crois
qu'ils ont là encore on a encore pas mal
de boulot sur la cause des femmes et
alors à chaque fois ce que je dis c'est
important c'est la cause des femmes non
pas contre les hommes
c'est avec les hommes 1 il faut que les
hommes y participent aussi
et la majorité le font extrêmement
volontiers on a encore du boulot et
c'est vrai que si il faut moi je reviens
un petit peu sur les quotas j'étais
contre à un moment donné de me dire
enfin pourquoi des quotas et c'est vrai
que la loi copé zimmermann en 2011 qui
avait introduit les quotas dans les
conseils d'administration ou fait leur
chemin et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
quand on voit que au sein du cac40 ya
aucune femme dirigeante que dans les 120
plus grandes entreprises
française en fait il ya que 17% des
femmes qui sont au comex donc on a
encore du boulot
et s'il faut des quotas pour booster je
pense qu'il faut aussi savoir les
utiliser et je pense à nouveau qu'il
faut pas aller sur des effets de manche
sur le féminisme ou à outrance il faut
travailler sur le fond et le quotidien
par des actions quotidiennes et là c'est
vrai que par exemple l'action de la
région ile-de-france sur par exemple
tout ce qui est travaillé sur les contre
les préjugés contre l'autocensure avec
des subventions à des associations qui
pousse les jeunes filles à aller dans
les filières techniques les
scientifiques parce qu'on s'est rendu
compte que les filières techniques et
scientifiques c'était des filières plus
tôt pour les garçons puisque l'on se
demande pourquoi
voilà donc c'est ce travail de fond
qu'il faut continuer de faire pour la
pour la cause des femmes à l'égalité
femmes-hommes
et d'ailleurs je voudrais dire que le la
région ile de france a eu la belle
il ya quelques mois d'égalité femmes
hommes parce que c'est vrai qu'on est
très très attaché à ce à ce débat alors
qu'elle est choquée j'ai encore du
boulot pour revenir à l'avortement c'est
vraiment un acte effectivement batteur
qui ferment a permis d'éviter plaindre
qu'à perdre sa compère et médical avec
quito des femmes des partis laïques
bougent et faire avorter notamment faut
aussi être être vigilant parce qu'il ya
des mouvements anti avortement et il
faut être très vigilant sur ce point là
alors le projet de loi dit dépendre à
l'encontre de ce que je vais tenter via
des mouvements quand même deux
deux personnes qui sont contre
l'avortement des médecins qui refuse
d'avorter aussi donc il faut continuer à
être vigilants et continuer de vivre ce
crime at-il l'égalité hommes femmes
et c'est vrai que sur ce sujet d'un
avocat part du travail genevois bien sûr
dematic savaria le couvert il
difficultés à évoluer dans sa carrière
il faut rien lâcher pour conclure parce
qu'il ne reste plus beaucoup de temps
stéphanie mont-saint-vincent courage et
interrogé des iris au fond est-ce que
les grands mouvements sociaux ne se font
pas contre le droit existant est contre
la loi
si je peux commencer je sais pas si ça
se fait contre la loi mais la loi en
tout cas la compagne qu'elle le fasse
contrainte ou parfois avec un petit peu
la vence elle le fait il ya eu trois
vagues en fait en droit de féminisme
juridique où quelque sorte l'égalité des
droits d'abord à partir du 19ème siècle
et jusqu'à la libération avec le droit
de vote pour les femmes il ya eu
légalité des corps ensuite avec les
années 60 une familiale puis vg et puis
maintenant des plans un mouvement
d'égalité réelle avec la questionde à
paris près effectivement la question des
quotas etc et demain qu'est ce qu'il va
y avoir peut-être je sais pas devin mais
je pense qu'aujourd'hui la féminité
enfin pendant de la femme
interroge la place de l'homme aussi dans
la société et donc de la masculinité est
donc aujourd'hui on peut probablement
être un homme et être féministe
en fait en s'interrogeant sur la place
simplement de l'homme et de ce que c'est
qu'être un homme dans la société
égalitaire d'aujourd'hui c'est
probablement en fait être je passe c'est
la continuation du troisième c'est une
quatrième vague féministe mais c'est
sans doute qui est en france à passer en
homo jean charles agou
du sujet bien évidemment ce que j'admire
c'est le courage de ses 343 femmes à
l'époque parce qu'il fallait un courage
mais l'essentiel est il bien au delà de
tout ce qu'on peut imaginer à l'heure
actuelle et technologues c'était
extraordinaire
le temps est fini mais je voudrais juste
un hameau sandrine grand bang et anne
père brio les élections régionales et
départementales il faut qu'elles se
tiennent en joue pas en un mot oui oui
oui oui oui oui d'accord ok ben on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler
et comme je serais probablement candidat
peut-être de vous inviter à nouveau pour
parler des élections régionales et
départementales merci merci à tous
il y avait plein d'autres sujets qu'on a
pas le temps d'aborder mais on aura
l'occasion de se retrouver
merci à tous et à très vite pour un
nouveau numéro de paf
[Musique]